hi there today we're going to take a
short look at reinforcement learning
with augmented data this paper is by
Michael askin Kim in Lee and others from
UC Berkeley and NYU so the reason why
this is a short look is because I
believe the statements made in the paper
are quite short and small but they are
quite grandiose so we'll dive into it
the paper basically combines two things
reinforcement learning and data
augmentation now reinforcement learning
we've talked about a number of times
it's basically where an agent is in a
world and has to learn to solve an
optimization problem by repeatedly
interacting with the world you can see
here for example this is the walker task
where this walker thing it has two feet
and basically needs to stand upright and
walk for a number of steps the further
you go the better so by repeatedly
trying this and getting better and
better at it that is reinforcement
learning the second part is the data
augmentation now data augmentation is a
pretty standard practice in supervised
learning what does it mean so if you
have a supervised learning task for
example an image classification task
here is a picture of a cat and the label
is cat then you can feed this through
your neural network right to arrive at a
loss and but you only have so many
pictures right you have a database and
maybe you have I don't know 1 million
images ok usually what people do is they
go let's say a number of times like 20
or 50 times through that database to
basically have the model learn each
image multiple times but what turns out
to be more successful is if you do data
augmentation that means you have an
in-between layer right here that takes
this image and some modifies it in some
small way this could be for example it
blocks out part of the image so it
simply blocks out the square here
and then you feed that through the the
model and then the next time the image
comes up it does something different for
example it randomly crops the image to
only the top right part here and then
the next time it does a bit of a color
jitter and then the next time it goes to
grayscale and so on so supervised
learning has found data augmentation to
be quite beneficial because not only do
you make the model learn what this
picture is but you also make the model
kind of learn some small variations of
that picture where you can be pretty
sure they would not change the label so
you would not feed the model false
information that generally makes it more
robust to test time discrepancies so
this paper has basically claims if you
want to do reinforcement learning if you
do simply do data augmentation with the
input data to that reinforcement
learning it works much much much better
now of course we can expect since in
supervised learning this as a general
trick that it would do something for
reinforcement learning as well but this
paper basically claims that this one
plugin like here so this is basically
you plug this into your pipeline in
reinforcement learning this is basically
as much of a gain as pretty much the
last five years of research on on
reinforcement learning on these things
so let's dive into it this paper
proposes just what I said just plug in
the date augmentation and then do
reinforcement learning on the Augmented
data they use these data augmentations
so crop we've already discussed it's a
random crop grayscale means that the
picture goes to gray black and white
with a certain probability cut out means
that there's a little touch missing like
I said cut out color the same but in a
random color flip means you've lipped
the image horizontally or vertically
according to a random probability
Tate is the same but you instead of flip
you rotate it random conf means you
randomly convolve it with a filter in
this case some red or blue or yellow
filters and color jitter means that you
can jitter around the colors in a sort
of in a sort of way that doesn't mess up
the image too much so you basically just
kind of change the colors on the image
but the overall image still looks the
same the only thing you have to you have
to pay attention to is that so in your
reinforcement learning pipeline usually
if you have a walker like this what you
want to do is you have your network here
and then you have you know your policy
and your value function if you don't
know what these are
we'll have we haven't I've treated them
many times in reinforcement learning
videos what you want to do is you simply
don't want to take this one current
observation in here but sometimes you
want to take kind of the stacked of the
last few frames so that the model kind
of gets an idea what happened during
let's say the last one second right so
it can it can determine in this Walker
for example it's not only important
where the legs are which are appear
right now it is also important their
momentum how they're moving right and
you can you can area you can determine
that from the last few frames so
sometimes it's beneficial to feed the
last few frames and they say the
important thing here is that these
augmentations are applied consistently
across the stacked frames so basically
you select on an augmentation and on the
scale of that augmentation and then you
apply it to these stacked frames all the
same and then in the next forward pass
you have a different set of stacked
frames then you can decide on a on a
different augmentation so that's
basically the only difference between
the supervised setting and this setting
is that you have to consistently apply
the augmentation you have to
consistently apply this here and during
training so they formulate the
classic approximate policy optimization
here which is an actor critic method and
the only time you have to really pay
attention is when you plug the
observation into these models here right
here
then it needs to be the same
augmentation sorry the same observation
so that means the observation augmented
with the same data with the same
augmentation procedures alright getting
it together cool so when you do this
when you do that let's say when applying
our ad which is the Ratan random data
augmentation - si si which is soft actor
critic right our date augmentations are
applied to the observation past the q
and pi so uh sorry this is the thing up
here this is soft actor critic which is
the state of the art of policy algorithm
for continuous control problems and also
you have to pay attention that when you
feed the observations they're the same
observations like here and here and then
proximal policy optimization is the one
is a state-of-the-art on policy
algorithm for learning a continuous or
discrete control policy okay so as I
said they simply drop this in there and
then it turns out they outperform or
match performance of many many baselines
here you can see curl I've made a video
on curl which is another way of
augmenting or pre-training a for
reinforcement learning then
state-of-the-art things like planet or
dreamer I've made a video on dreamer as
well and then pixel si si and state si
si is sort of a cheating algorithm
because it has access to this state
whereas all the other methods only have
access to the to the pixels and you can
see that the data augmentation method
which is basically just plain or ll
plane
si si plus the posted eight augmentation
outperforms in many times all of these
other baselines now here is a criticism
of me in order they never investigate
they simply say wow this reaches the
same performance or outperforms these
other methods now so it's the state of
the art algorithm it's important to note
here that this is on the DM control 100k
and 500k benchmarks which means that
there's a limit on the number of I
believe frames from these control tasks
that you get so you either get 100k or
you get 500k frames so the difficulty is
learning from limited data it's not
state-of-the-art
reinforcement learning method overall it
is the state of the art on this
particular task on learning from limited
data now while I can believe that the
augmentation would help here
ie it is completely unclear whether or
not the augmentation gives the same
benefits as like something like dreamer
or whether the benefits from dreamer and
the benefits from data augmentation are
completely orthogonal so in this paper
given that the claim is so simple that
they make I wouldn't I would expect like
an investigation what happens if I do
dreamer plus the data augmentation maybe
they've done it somewhere and I just
haven't seen it but it just seems like
they they put this on the base basic or
algorithm and then they claim well look
here it works well but they never show
that so it could be that dreamer all
this architecture what it simply does is
basically recover these gains that you
could get by data augmentation or it
could be that it actually does something
different but just reaches the same
amount of gain right it just reaches the
same amount and improvement and by
combining them you could improve it
further so not not just to get like a
better
but combining the two would actually
give a lot of hints as to whether or not
this augmentation works in line with the
other methods or whether the other
methods are really doing something
meaningfully different or not but this
is just not done here and so they go
into the they go into a a question of
which date augmentations contribute the
most and they get to the point where
they say random crop is extremely
effective so they have this table here
where they just basically combine two
augmentations and so you see so for
example this thing here means that you
apply grayscale and then the rotate
augmentation and that gets you to
whatever 300 points in this Walker if
you apply crop and then crop it gets you
to nine hundred and twenty points and
beats everything else so they they say
okay crop is the most the most effective
and I have I have the sneaking suspicion
that these augmentations are so
effective it's simply because of how we
set up these tasks right these
reinforcement learning tasks they don't
tend to be a real world they tend to be
somewhat simulated and as you can see
here the the image is pretty clear so
you can pretty clearly see that here is
a thing there's no natural background or
whatnot it's procedurally generated
right there are these stars that could
confuse the model a bit but still it is
so easy visually this task that I'm
going to guess the whole reason why
these image augmentations help is simply
because of the way these reinforcement
learning tasks right now are set up and
I'm would guess that if we had
reinforcement learning in something like
the real world that the image
augmentation methods would help in about
the way they help unsupervised tasks in
in the same data for example image net
so that is my sneaking suspicion and
this paper I I want to say it's sort of
over claims it's how how absolutely
great this works of course it works
great on these things but I think there
needs to be an investigation of where
why so here they have some attention
maps on where the algorithm focuses and
you can see when there is no data
augmentation it sort of focuses on good
points but when you do crop it focuses
on this ridge here which makes sense
right because that's the thing that
needs to be kind of vertical in order
for the Walker to be stable and in if
you do other things then you can see it
it doesn't really focus it focuses on
different things so the crop method
seems to make the model focus on the
most important part of the image and
it's the same with the cheetah task here
so if you don't do augmentation and some
of the augmentation you can see that it
actually focuses on some of these
background stars whereas in the cropped
version it focuses on not on the stars
but actually on the cheetah as a whole
which probably makes sense now again I
have a bit of a I have a bit of worry
with these kinds of experiments because
we already know that crop will give you
a much better score right so who's to
say that if we could train this thing
here to the same score
it wouldn't be paying attention to the
same part what they're trying to make
clear here is that it is dependent on
the particular type of data augmentation
that the model gets a better grip on the
input but it is not really a valid
comparison if we know that the crop
agent performs a better score and it
could simply be that that's the reason
why the the attention is better right
that that it is actually solving the
problem better so I mean of course this
the fact that it's working better
due to the fact that you have crop
augmented the data but the fact that is
focusing on the correct parts is not a
property of the crop augmentation but
the property of the fact that it reaches
a higher score that was a long-winded
complaint but I hope you get what I mean
here the last thing they do is they
investigate generalization performance
so improving generalization on this open
area proc gen now as I understand it
this is a reinforcement learning task or
a suite of tasks where you have
procedurally generated levels so you can
sort of train on a bunch of levels and
then test the generalization to new
levels that you haven't seen before so
there's a jumper here and star pilots so
they seem like this like a jump and run
game or big fish I don't even know what
you have to do in big fish but you can
see that the levels seen here this is
one example and unseen so in in this
example the the background is very
different and I'm going to guess in the
jumper thing not only is the background
different but also the kind of generated
level how you have to jump is quite
different so they investigate whether or
not a agent trained on only the seen
ones can generalize to the unseen ones
and this table presents the results and
as you can see the are ad with the crop
or with other things outperform the
pixel paste based PPOs now there is some
nuance to this table here first of all
you can see that these this crop thing
is now only the winner in one of these
three tasks right in the in the big fish
thing in there is another augmentation
technique here that wins over at star
pilot but you can see the difference is
not that high and in the D
jumper with 200 levels so this is 100 or
200 levels the the original method is
even the best so here again I believe
this is evidence that that it is very
much an interaction of these
augmentations with the way the task is
set up and not the augmentations
themselves or the fact that you're
augmenting for example if we look at
this big fish we've seen okay the what
seems to change here is mainly the
background whereas in the jumper example
the entire level structure seems to
change so then the the augmentation all
of a sudden is not super effective
anymore actually hurts right so I'm just
not I'm just not super convinced by the
claims you're making here and one of the
claims I find is in particular read with
random crop achieves no weight this not
point down here oh yeah Jeeves 55.8%
gained over pixel-based PP oh okay
trained with 100 training levels
outperforms the pixel-based PPO with 200
training levels on both big fish and
star palate environment this shows that
data augmentation can be more effective
in learning generalizable
representations compared to simply
increasing the number of training
environments I this statement so again
how like why do you compare two
different things if you don't like if
you don't show that maybe they're
orthogonal in fact they are probably
orthogonal because even on the two
hundred levels you you gain over the
pixel-based PPO right so why the
comparison and then second of all so
here we see on the 100 levels this
method is better than the pixel-based
PPO and then they claim that okay they
they are even better on 100 levels than
the pixel-based PPO
200 levels and why that is true if you
know if if a is bigger than B then
probably a is going to be bigger than B
plus some Epsilon and right and and that
doesn't I just think that doesn't really
warrant their statement where they say
oh look this is even better so as if the
100 levels of additional training were
the standard measure of more data like
if there is going to be if you're better
at the beginning there's going to be a
certain amount of data
where you're still better than the other
method with more data and I don't find
this super duper surprising but they
make a big claim here out of this all
right
so in conclusion I hope I'm not too
harsh on this paper it is a cool paper
and of course it is cool findings but I
have a big suspicion that the
augmentation here works so well simply
because of how we set up these RL tasks
because they're visually quite let's say
easy and therefore these augmentations
that are also our sort of easy
abstractions of when an image is
visually similar because all of these
things write to us as humans we say
probably doesn't change anything if we
just rotate the image and we this is our
prejudice and we built this prejudice
into these simulators for the RL tasks
so they will match up extremely well
with these augmentations and that's the
reason I believe these things work and
maybe not as much the the fact that
you're augmenting okay well if you like
this video I invite you to check out the
paper subscribe to this channel tell all
your friends about it and leave a like
in the comment thank you very much and
bye bye